je vous ai écouté aujourd'hui à la voix
se fait mal aujourd'hui on se retrouve
sur ipad écoutez j'ai découvert des gens
qui développent le logiciel qui modifie
le visage par exemple pour devenir gros
devenir âgées avoir une moustache ça
j'aimerais bien ça par exemple aussi de
tout petit point nul on commence tout
avec celle qui rend les gens gros je me
demande à quoi je ressemblais ton gros
vu que là je suis carrément faim voire
même ficello parfait elle est parfaite
c'est parti je veux devenir gros aller
alors aux chiots ribes l'attend et c'est
carrément disproportionnée quoi entre le
bas et le haut du crâne vous bien mort
effect c'est quoi xxl sad à plusieurs
postes
c'est ridicule et si je me mets gros
avec le crâne rasé
les parfums il est tout lisse hybride
[ __ ] un dôme vraiment parfait quoi
assez bien fait pour le coup avec les
petits chemins sur le côté qui doit à
l'air totalement pédophiles c'est
affreux c'est juste affreux avec une
moustache en plus s'il vous plaît cette
première fait olala ménage peut séduire
toute la terre entière 2006 elle c'est
trop même le cas ce trésor il a grossi
goy bizarrement iron man gros ça donne
quoi
la bouche à bâle à elle est parfaite web
serait bon droite à bages et ça que ça
va être tabac presse et si je mets une
moustache iron man le ironman espagnol
et si je devais choisir un put un mec de
marsatac c'est génial au bordel ça lui
fait juste énorme dôme avec mes vieux
cheveux aplatis dégueulasse en dessous
pas y'a aucun style sur cette image on
ne peut devenir gros en temps réel ça
marche super bien en plus ça le pire
palaja peu la bouche de travers ils sont
préfère ça que les miss se serait
parfait je veux prendre un peu de vie 7
ce nom si un visage rien visage ya un
visage et vous avez grossi louis saez
bordels même les logiciels ils veulent
pas eux
babouche à l'époque totalement ça quand
je tousse quoi on peut devenir âgées
s'il vous plaît enfin en 2048
c'est troublant
j'espère juste un truc parce que la
barre d'adolescents foireux sur un mec
de 60 ans sarko est même très très
bizarre et hulk vieux ça donne quoi
attendait ça ne pète énervé la tuque
dans 50 ans il sait comment c'est nul
mais ce qui est encore plus dur c'est la
tête de ce mec juste à côté à total de
pression non mais il a juste de ride
comme belhadj année il a déjà des rites
de base en fait a par contre eu que
graulhet ya un style et la ja mix booth
on peut mixer deux photos peut être
marrant ça et je peux choisir avec qui
je vais être mixées fusion je sens que
ça va être horrible alors mais plus de
peur d'offenser temps avec pas il fait
un truc mieux quoi il fait juste
cinquante fois moins peur et djobo le
montage le plus vulgaire de france en
fait je pense qu'on demande une photo il
ya un mec de sept ans derrière c'est son
taf est arrivé il fait le montage et si
je mixe avec les gens qui me donnent là
comme mademoiselle voulait éviter aux
comment je suis canon c'est bouleversant
et si je deviens noirs ou métis
elle suivra beau gosse gravograph
j'aurais dû admettiez sur déconner
j'aurais été trop beau gosse square en
plus avant une grosse [ __ ] et drôle ça
et squeeze bébé à le bébé tremblade fait
vite royal comme ça tu sais tu valoir
dans son petit berceau s'attend à voir
un petit ange qui donne rien et regarde
comme ça fixement et si j'étais
asiatiques
comment chez quand je serai ouais bah du
coup je vais pas les yeux [ __ ] donc ça
paye d'oise atik d'un coup quoi toute la
photo et asiatiques sauf les yeux mais
je sais plus important par contre l'aja
besoins qui vont plus fait les faits à
un grossissement du visage le mène de
sept ans qui fait le montage s'est
trompé là en ont déjà de voir le
résultat
l'enfant de sept ans fait son montage oh
là là j'ai un vrai budget le book de
brad pitt s'il vous plaît messieurs
dames j'aimerais rester comme ça à tout
jamais donc je vais voilà je vais vous
parler comme ça maintenant ça va johnny
depp au c'est dérangeant c'est moche
au revoir aux
petit style un micro style voilà
vraiment bon d'indiquer medic et mes
rêves à l'isie dans l'allier nul en est
il des bals champêtres les gens 2011 et
au mahdi rigole et si brad pitt était en
fait une bimbo assez troublant mais
pourquoi il faut une bouche de vraiment
en plastique quoi arrêter on personne
même ça je serai là l'enfant ne s'est
occupé le montage va pas du tout réussir
à il ya un problème là est-ce que ce que
vous êtes a de quoi être jalouse
oh oui à tort je suis calme on
l'attendait vraiment une belle enfin un
bon gros situé e gli booth
alors ça va nous rendre très moche
apparemment seul pas réaliste quoi ce
droit dans un deux un cartoon dans un
dessin animé
il va même salle il est dans y'a pas
besoin un bâtard je me revois sans
cheveux parce que je sais qu'un jour
j'en aurai plus et je veux être préparés
psychologiquement à ce moment je me fais
peur là là j'ai peur gg ça va pas mais
il va falloir éteindre cet ipad et ne
plus jamais lancé s'est appuyé sur les
connais je veux pas mal futur éteindre
et dans la légende souvient pas de cette
vidéo gshc la pluie si yo hockey news
hippiques fléau lille album et là on a
visé haut ont démarché squeeze on fout
le bordel dans ta vie tu héros comme lui
car on peut rater nos ânes trop faire le
beau devant l'ordi avoir la dalle comme
jumbo tu bouges ton siège pendant que tu
joues les petits tard je vous y est
aussi né dans rares camp des saints de
girard je vais squeeze en squeez est
j'ai failli vomir par terre et de jeu
faire le con nous aussi on peut le faire
dans les bacs on les suivait les
bas-fonds verbe annoncé que veut le
faire vous aussi à jour garde
gharios tout le monde c'est big flo et
oli alors aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur
un super jeu on va le tester ensemble
avec jumbo